hey everyone hope you're doing well
first of all i wanted to thank nordvpn
for sponsoring today's video
so stick around to the end for the
sponsored message or click the link in
the description box down below to get
the discount
so after posting my wind down routine a
few weeks ago
i got some requests to post my morning
routine as well mornings used to be my
least favorite part of the day
because i used to have a lot of trouble
waking up but
now it's easily my most favorite because
of the routine i've built
in fact this video will show you my
weekday morning routine
but i also do this on the weekends too
mornings give me time to get physically
and mentally ready for the day ahead
so i make sure to take each morning at
my own pace as much as possible
and to enjoy each moment to give my
brain and body
time to wake up for whatever the day
brings anyways
i hope you enjoy
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
good morning good morning thank you for
taking the dogs out you're welcome
coffee
so apparently scott has taken out ellie
but not kona
which is usually the case one of us will
take one dog out
and then the other will take the other
one we're taking him out separately
right now because conan
needs a walk in the morning he can't
just go
out in the backyard that we have
prepared for him and worked so hard
to get and so i will be taking him
on our morning walk oh
california sunshine hello
[Music]
check
[Music]
yes
[Music]
breakfast time i'm just having pears
i also need to stay around the dogs
while i eat
because ellie has major fomo and if i go
into a different room
she will follow me and not eat her
breakfast bother have breakfast together
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
it's a little bit past nine finally on
my desk
and uh so yeah i'm gonna just spend some
time
writing into my bullet journal for what
are all the things that i need to do
today
because that helps me stay focused and
fake really identify like the core
three or four things that i'm trying to
do and then
my day will basically be started then
[Music]
wanted to show you my new bullet journal
spread by the way
i updated it like right after i made
that bullet journal video
but basically here in this column i have
monday through friday
like space for each day to write out my
couple of things that i'm going to do
every day
and then here's just a rolling task list
of all the things that i need to do
for the rolling task list i also have
like a priority thing
so i specify whether it's high medium or
low priority or whether to move it next
week
i got a little calendar here too and
it's been simple it's easy it doesn't
take a lot of time for me to like
make this spread every week which is why
i think i've been liking it
it's been enough to just like over a
week identify
what i need to do basically oh also
quick thing
last night i replaced the keycaps on
this keyboard i'm gonna make a video
about
uh my favorite keyboards in a little bit
so stay tuned for that and if you
haven't subscribed already then do so
but this is definitely one of those
that'll be on there and i'll post
like a full review of what i think about
it in that video and i just want to take
a moment to say thank you to the sponsor
of today's video nordvpn
nordvpn is an amazing vpn service that i
use all the time
i know a lot of us are not going out in
cafes and traveling as much anymore but
it's still a really important thing to
have a vpn
as it protects your data while you're in
public they don't do any data logging
and they have double data encryption for
increased anonymity they have
24 7 customer support as well as a 30
day money back guarantee
in case you don't like the service
mobile vpn has unlimited bandwidth and
they even have a chrome extension so
that's just super easy to use
so because they're a sponsor of this
video you can get a two-year plan plus
one additional month with a huge
discount by going to nordvpn.com
myuco or use code myuco thank you again
nordvpn for sponsoring
anyway i hope you liked this video this
was my morning routine that i
do like every single day i found a lot
of peace and comfort in having a routine
that i can stick to
that allows me to just like wake up for
the day slowly and get energized for the
day
so if you liked it let me know i would
love for you to subscribe and be part of
the family so that you can see
incoming videos like the keyboard ones
and others let me know what's an
important part of your morning routine
in the comments down below and i will
see you next time
bye